hi i'm alyssia cara and today i'll be
doing the wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
i think i searched this this is probably
me
looking for answers if anyone knows hit
me up was
alessia cara was alessia carra in moana
technically i was not i did the end
credits song
but a lot of people especially kids when
i meet them they think that i
played moana which is a very uh rough
conversation i have to have and be like
well it wasn't me but thank you i think
the hair
made people think that i played moana
but i did not it was played by aoli
korvala who's amazing um i just sang the
song was alessia cara on american idol i
was not
i'd be too scared to do something like
that i'm also canadian so that probably
wouldn't even work anyway
was alessia carr on the voice no i was
not i don't know why that's like a
commonly asked thing i was never on any
singing
shows or anything like that what team
would you be on if like everyone turned
around their chair
that's tough i love i love kelly
clarkson i think she's so good and gwen
they're both amazing maybe glenn does
alessia cara
does alessia cara sing how far i'll go
yes um i seen the the end credits
version of
how far i'll go from does alessia carr
have siblings yes i have a younger
brother
um who is 20 years old now so he's not
very young anymore well he's still young
but he's not little anymore
i'm definitely a protective older sister
yeah i mean i always was but i feel like
now that i'm
an adult and not a kid um i'm like
more conscious of like the world and i i
find that i'm like becoming more of a
warrior which is weird because i never
used to be that way
i was always protective but now i like
worry all the time but he's like
you know leave me alone get off my back
he's he's
smarter than i am so i think he should
be more worried about me
does alessia car have tattoos i have
this little
sailboat i have this smiley face that is
pretty much gone i have to get that like
touched up and i have this
band-aid on the back of my arm that's
way too big
but that's it's the beauty of decisions
on a whim does alessia car speak other
languages
i speak italian because my family is is
from there and i'm trying to learn
spanish and i know like a few sentences
in japanese but
that doesn't count obviously but i would
love to
learn does alexia carr write her own
music yes i do
um the first album that i ever put out i
made was sebastian cole who's
phenomenal but then the second album and
everything
after that as well um i've i've written
completely by myself which is something
that i
take a lot of pride in because i've
always wanted to be a songwriter and
good at what i do and i feel like i've
not mastered it but i'm getting to a
place where i think i'm
good at it and that makes me really
happy so i hope to continue writing
everything
uh myself in the future too it's kind of
hard to write when you're in quarantine
because there's like
a lack of experiences to write about my
life is sort of stagnant right now in
every aspect but um
it's fun because i get to pull from my
imagination more who alessia cara
who is alessia cara married to i think i
searched this
this is probably me looking for answers
if anyone knows
hit me up that'd be great to know in
advance i've never even been in like a
public
relationship really so it's it's kind of
funny that people associate me with
marriage but
who knows we'll see who discovered
alessia cara
the first person to discover me was
karin perez i always wanted to be a
singer and i think i'd always hope to be
discovered in some way
far in the future but when i was posting
youtube videos i didn't think
i was going to be discovered from there
that was just my way of like getting
used to singing in front of people or
for like some sort of audience but
i never thought i'd get discovered after
that i don't know who is alessio cara i
don't know alyssia cara is just
a person who makes music and writes
music and uh
i think i'm realizing that i'm multiple
things in one
and that's like what people are you know
they're not just one thing they're like
there's like so many facets to us how
alessia clara
how alessia cara became famous again
corinne perez
found a youtube video of mine um where i
was covering this song called sweater
weather by the neighborhood
from there i started making a bunch of
songs with
someone named sebastian cole who's
amazing and
these two brothers from toronto who are
a producer duo named kuya productions
and we just got in this little tiny
studio and every day after school i
would go in and write a bunch of music
one of those songs was a song called
here that i later released after
being signed to def jam on soundcloud
and then
it was one of those things that just
kind of grew naturally it took
a while for it to get on the radio but
then once it did people started
knowing about that song and knowing my
name and then that's how everything sort
of goes in there
i don't call myself famous i don't like
to say that i just say i do this for a
living how alessia car was discovered
off of
my youtube covers how tall is alessia
cora
i am i believe either five one or five
two
everybody is like shocked to see how
short i am i don't know why people just
expect me to be a lot bigger
but i'm tiny i feel like i'm the kid who
should be meeting them
it's so funny but one time i met kim
kardashian and i expected her to be so
tall and she was shorter than me
i think she was the first person i met
first celebrity i met that was
shorter than me um which was kind of
shocking she was wearing heels too i'm
like
whoa you're really tiny where alessia
cara where was alessia cara born i was
born in
a place or a city called mississauga
ontario
which is in canada and then when i was
four i moved to brampton ontario which
is where i
pretty much grew up i think brampton has
more of a reputation than mississauga
brampton is like
we kind of get the short end of the
stick all the time like people make fun
of brampton
all the time it's like not particularly
cool if you're from there i think now
it's becoming that way but it's like a
known thing within toronto that brampton
is like
sort of the underdog it's very easy to
pick on we just have like our own weird
culture
so yeah where does alessia cara live now
wouldn't you like to know
i'm not telling you where did alessia
carr go to school i went to
school in brampton uh it was a catholic
school
called cardinal ambrosic secondary
school and we had to wear
blazers and khaki pants it was not fun
to wear those things because you're
always hot
and you have to like if you couldn't
even roll with the sleeves
you get in trouble for like wearing it
the wrong way so i have the pants
um that i got like all my friends to
sign on the last day so there's like all
these signatures on these ugly khaki
pants and i still have the blazer too
with its shoulder pads and all but girls
and boys had to wear the same exact
thing like there was no
different thing like there was no fun
like skirts or like little
i don't know like sweaters or cardigans
it was just
it was just blazers it was horrible
where are alessia carr's parents from
both my parents are from the south of
italy
this place called calabria and that's
where they met
and sometimes i wish that i was born
there
but i'm also glad to be from canada too
what alessia carr
what is lester cara doing now i am just
doing what everyone else is doing just
waiting for this whole thing to be over
and chilling living life and writing a
lot
what is leslie carr famous for i guess
my music
i hope that's that's what people know me
for my songs
and the fact that i sing stuff what is
alessia car's nationality this is a
funny one because
if you go online every day a few times a
day actually every single day there's
there's a person that discovers that i
am
italian and basically white it makes me
laugh because they're
like in shock that i'm like not latina
or something i am pretty racially
ambiguous i think that's because my
family's from the south of italy and
everyone from the south is like a little
bit
darker and more olive skinned i got the
curls but i'm italian
what is alessia cara's social media my
twitter is at alessia clara and my
instagram is alessia's mainly is alessia
carr is alessia cara related to irene
kara
i am not she is a a singer from
a little bit before my time i believe it
was like either maybe 80s or 90s i'm not
exactly sure but she
she's a singer-songwriter and people
always think that we're related
i assume because of our last names but
maybe because we look alike
possibly our hair sometimes is alessia
carr left-handed
no i am i'm right-handed except for when
i'm playing
like mini golf then i'm for some reason
i'm left-handed i don't know why i
didn't even realize i was doing it until
someone pointed it out
is alessia carr religious i used to be
a lot more religious than i am now i
think now it's sort of turned into like
some sort of like
spirituality i'll just say i believe in
god and
uh i believe in just being a good person